this one was interesting saw it a few
hours ago
brett favre was apparently on espn's
first take and
he said that his former backup doug
peterson they were together in green bay
peterson and the eagles should have kept
nick foles
and not carson wentz and remember they
had a point where i thought
it was a a very tough decision i don't
know how much thought they put into it
after the 2018 season but i thought that
by
getting to the final eight almost
beating the saints
should have been enough to get them to
at least sit down and have a careful and
serious conversation about keeping nick
foles instead of carson wentz and we
know that
the how it turned out foles left wentz
got a huge contract now he's the guy
farv says they kept the wrong guy here's
doug peterson reacting to what brett
favre had to say
i respect uh brett's opinion you know i
mean
yeah we are friends but um i haven't i
haven't talked to him and he's entitled
to that and uh
um that's about it when the decision had
to be made in the organization
it even though personnel decisions like
that are usually tough
it probably wasn't that difficult for
you guys was
anyone beating down the door to do a
different thing
with you in regards to nick they're
keeping nick over carson
no carson's our guy carson's our draft
pick carson's the guy
that uh is going to carry us and and
and lead this football team and and
listen everybody's entitled to their own
opinion those aren't those aren't my
words those aren't howie's words
jeffrey's words those are his words i
mean that
i respect that opinion but whatever he
wants to say that that's fine and
we're going to remain friends it doesn't
doesn't bother me one way or the other
all i know is that carson wentz is our
guy
well everybody knows carson once is
their guy they
traded up to the second overall position
in the 2016 draft to get him
and then they decided to keep him
instead of nick foles
so they doubled down on carson wentz
after the 2018 season
second straight year that wentz had a
season-ending injury second straight
year that full stepped in and did well
in the postseason after being super bowl
mvp
almost getting back to the nfc
championship game and then they tripled
down
when they paid him a contract worth 33
million or so in new money per year
he's their guy necessarily he's their
guy
through 2021 based upon the contract the
first year that they can reasonably get
out of it because the 2021 salary is
already fully guaranteed
unless they're going to find someone to
trade for him and now would not be the
time
to sell high if you're trying to move
the carson months contract based on how
he's played this year
he's your guy you've made the choice
you've made the bed
you got to sleep in it for another
season and a half shireen
yeah absolutely i mean what else do you
expect them to say at this point they've
made their choice
they have to back him up and that was my
first observation he's got to say oh
yeah we made the wrong decision
but on the other hand mike let's not
pretend that nick foles has gone over to
chicago and absolutely lit it up
because he hasn't he's barely ahead of
carson winston passer reign he has an
83-8 passer rating he has 10 touchdowns
he has seven interceptions
this is a guy who's never started more
than 11 games
in a season he's not a starting
quarterback for
game after game after game year after
year after year he's proved that that's
why he's
been to so many different teams that's
why he's
not stuck with one team and been the
starter be so
it was an easy decision for the eagles
to
make when they had spent so much on
carson wentz in
in draft equity to keep him over nick
foles nick foles is a career backup and
yes he's one of the top two career
back best backups in nfl history no
question about that
but it's not like that he's a great
starter that he's
brett favre for instance who you you let
go they didn't make that decision and
who knows nick foles may be back at
philadelphia at some point as the back
up to carson wentz and he takes over the
job when
carson fails so they had to make that
decision
you and i rarely disagree i disagree
with you on this one
because there's an alternate universe
out there where the eagles kept nick
foles
moved on from carson wentz provided
blocking
for nick foles which he does not have in
chicago you know he's got to get rid of
the ball
far sooner than he wants to he's getting
thrown around behind a crappy offensive
line
he doesn't have the weapons there
although they don't really have a great
assortment of weapons in philly
the weapons in philly right now i'd say
are better than the weapons in chicago
especially with terry cohen
gone for the year for the past five or
six weeks i just think that the way that
foles played in that offense with doug
peterson it worked it clicked and dollar
for dollar
you could have kept foals for less a lot
less
dollar for dollar than you could have
kept carson wentz
and the time to move carson wentz would
have been after the 2018
season because the value has gone down
with the contract with the performance
this year
and i don't know what's happened you
know you've got to just
roll this one up into a ball and throw
it into the trash can and try it again
next year
and and look if they don't get to the
playoffs this year
right now they're in first place in the
nfc east but obviously they're not very
good but if they don't make it to the
playoffs this year
next year wentz is on notice and doug
peterson's on notice because in all the
years that jeffrey lurie has owned the
team
anytime you fail to get to the playoffs
in consecutive years as a head coach
you're gone now the super bowl may help
peterson but andy reid two straight
years no playoffs first time that ever
happened
gone chip kelly two straight years no
playoffs gone
so i think next year is going to be a
huge year for carson wentz and it could
be a huge year for doug peterson and
maybe for gm howie roseman
i do think mike they have a quarterback
problem in philadelphia no question
and he is going to get one more year and
carson wentz is going to be put on
notice and
we'll see what he can do but he'll also
have the chance probably in the playoffs
if they don't make the playoffs this
year it's a huge fail because i
think they are the best team probably in
the nfc east i don't think they're going
to win
many games but i don't think it takes
many games to win the nfc east and he
can go and see if he can
win his first playoff game he'll
probably get that chance
but he's got to do something over the
course of the playoffs this season
into next season he's got to be better
whatever's happened to him
he's got to figure it out whether it's
bad weapons offensive line and disarray
with all the injuries whatever it is
the eagles have to figure that out or
they will have a new quarterback come
2022
and maybe his name is nick foles
i think wentz is overly conscious and
aware
of all the times they've gone to bat for
him
trading up to draft him keeping him
instead of falls paying him and
he's in a funk and he just has the
demeanor of a guy who thinks he can fix
everything in one fell swoop and it
doesn't work that way you gotta you
gotta calm down
you gotta settle down you gotta go about
your business you're not gonna
fix it all with one throw with one play
with one game it's a process and uh
look the eagles last year they were five
and seven
and they ended up finishing strong and
winning the division and they very well
made and that may go a long way toward
addressing these concerns
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure
to hit subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports